so the president wants to close Gitmo
and it don't get most suicidal the
president is turning a bastion of
freedom into a catch-and-release program
but these men aren't curious trout
they're radical Islamic piranhas
gobbling up every Christian minnow in
every stream now there are some who say
the men aguanta nomo are harmless and to
those people I say you can't handle the
truth do you even know who's still in
Guantanamo there's nati lammer Ozma
Nelson Annie a man whose cousin's
neighbor's dog was adopted by the niece
of a driver of a top al-qaeda members
mother-in-law he should rot in jail cuz
he and the others are dangerous now more
than ever some have been held for over a
decade you can't just close SeaWorld and
expect Shamu to play nice at the public
pool you can't just release these people
into the wild know if anything you've
got to create a habitat for them to
re-enter civilization with applebees and
American Idol or why not just seal it up
and walk away like a frat house bathroom
but moreover mr. president why and
something when it is proven to work it's
like canceling days of our lives and
saying okay everybody we've all seen
enough of Beau and hopes drama time to
pack it in there'd be hell to pay and if
14 years of fighting terror has proven
anything it's that there's always more
terror to be found and it's a good thing
that we've been fighting it and it's a
good thing that we had Guantanamo all
along to terrify that terror imagine if
we had closed it we wouldn't have fought
so much terror and that would have been
terrible and what's to become of Gitmo
once it closes maybe the present
we'll turn it into a resort where he and
the Castro brothers can toast poolside
to their newfound commie bro love I'll
take a pina colada and that's my gaping
opening good night and we're all going
to die the state of the Honu Yin I was
watching because Dance Moms was a rerun
mr. president you're killing America